red's rookie right-hander vladimir
gutierrez and i think what gutierrez has
done so well for this team is really be
able to give
david bell some length
farmers got it
badou flying down the line that was
close
kyle farmer's been so good because
there's no panic well guess what better
pick up the pace i don't know the next
ground ball that badou hits you'll see
the boys get rid of it a little quicker
grossman is a throwback player now he
has one of the top 10 sharpest launch
angles in the game
ground ball
tavata
and grossmantown
one two three
for gutierrez tyler alexander on the
mound for the tigers nick castiano steps
to the plate
the 2-1
grounded to third gobbled up by
candelario and tyler alexander uses just
eight pitches to retire the reds miguel
coburn leading off followed by
candelario castro here in the second
into his motion the three to miguel
fastball way inside didn't really look
interested
in throwing miguel a strike he didn't
come close miguel the short cautiously
three infielders stacked to the right in
the full shift the 2-2 is swinging a
soft ground ball down the third base
line
handed and throw down to first pulled
bottle
gutierrez bare-handed it nice and easy
gunned it to first but the fastball was
high and wide and error puts runners at
first and second castro homered
yesterday back-to-back homers for the
first time in his career basketball
the o2 a bullet to right center that'll
find the alley cabrera scores easily
candelario rounding third he's on his
way home he will score
and
harold castro delivers a two-run double
here in the second and now eugenio
suarez will come to the plate it's just
a grind
suarez
high in the air deep left sing it loud
25 on the year
dingers on back to back days
off speed pitch looked like a change up
and look at the extension of the swing
the balance in his swing don't want to
say he's back but he might be back
great swing
aquino
two-two swinging a mess cut her away
aquino fell across home plate after the
big swing and miss first strikeout for
tyler alexander that'll bring up delano
de shields here's the 2-2
swung on and missed in back-to-back
punch-outs for tyler alexander ends the
cincinnati second we head to the third
tigers up 2-1 it'll be the top of their
order brings up jonathan scope
first pitch swinging a fly ball left
field down the line way
back and gone upper deck left field
first home run in a month for jonathan
scope that's got to be a good feeling
number 19 makes it a 3-1 tigers lead
here in the third well we talked about
gutierrez being able to spin that spin
the breaking balls here's a hanging
breaking ball
that jonathan scope unleashes on
cabrera waits on the 1-1
off the end of the bat slowly back to
the mound this time gutierrez takes his
time tigers do get one back thanks to
jonathan scobe's
421-foot bomb jonathan india at the
plate he popped out his first time up
right-handed batter with an upright open
stance cox about high over the right
shoulder here's the another o2 foul
tipped into the glove of garneau third
strikeout of the night for tyler
alexander and there are two reds outs
here in the third good action here
looking good our motion this ball is
going down
the 1-2 right down the middle and he
gets him looking two strikeouts in the
second two strikeouts here in the third
for tyler alexander how about some help
from jamer candelario the payoff to
candelario
fly ball deep right center field going
back to shields that ball is out of here
chamber candelario flexes a solo bomb to
lead off the fourth and the tigers
extend their lead boy just stay right on
that doesn't pull off it right up the
middle in the band box that plays nice
sure does reyes grounded to second his
first time
to left center field and over the head
of aquino
it's hammered off the wall and reyes
jogs in with a one-out stand-up double
david bell
comes out wanting to talk to vladimir
gutierrez will he make the move
he will now
keep in mind this kid only josh fleming
of tampa and luis garcia of houston have
more wins among major league rookies
than vladimir gutierrez tigers have just
chased him after three and a third and
he goes to his bullpen and the
hard-throwing right-hander tony santiago
peter
right down the middle upper third strike
three
the pitch swing gonna miss struck him
out slider down and away back to back
strikeouts for tony santian out of the
reds bullpen reds are down three and see
if they can put a little rally together
here
the payoff pitch and castianos lines the
base head into right center field there
you go a nice controlled swing by
casianos kept his hands inside and hit a
solid line drive the right of center
it's just the second hit by the reds so
far tonight and straight up look he's
got a good view right there struck him
out tyler alexander has struck out three
of the last four max schrock hits for
delino de shields first pitch center
field badou blazing in will get there
truck loops in a single jonathan india
to play terrific rookie
india
shoots this one the deep
a long home run the rookies 18th of the
year
two runners in scoring position here to
start the sixth
and a grounder pass to diving shortstop
at kyle farmer
candelario scores it's an rbi single
oh
no with a blast to left field that ball
is gone
a two-run bomb from dustin garneau and
the tigers has opened it up here in
cincinnati and now here's miguel cabrera
to right field in front of
castillanos good hustle by badou and he
scores on the rbi single from miguel
cabrera
candelario a drive right field that's
down and all the way to the corner and
candelario's got himself an rbi double
put a 10 spot on the board for the
tigers justin garneau a couple of
strikeouts and a back-breaking home run
that he hit off of michael gibbons built
a two-run homer last time
pounds one to deep left field that's got
carrie that one is launched in off the
facade on the second deck
you know he just laid off a slider
two pitches earlier
i said man he looks good and he saw that
well
did he ever
just talking about not giving away at
bats gibby you want to stay in a lineup
right strikes out the first two times
and now the next two times he hits home
runs
now robbie grossman would like to get in
on the front swinging the fly ball right
field way down the line he gets to join
the fun
three runs shot for robbie grossman
listen to these tigers fans
a 14-4 lead in the seventh and the last
man standing for the reds
kyle farmer
goes down on strikes he sees
double-digit pitches
but the tigers post 15 runs 18 hits they
go deep five times
and the reds full
by a 10 spot